I think a lot of them are definitely
uneducated on you know what goes on in
Palestine but I do understand some of
their gripes and I think that you know
you talk about the textbook things I've
heard reports of textbooks being
infiltrated with Zionist uh you know
certain angles and I'm Jewish and you
know I don't want that I want my you
know students in my country learning you
know real truth and you know not you
know that's tampered with by some
special interest and so and I think
that's why a lot of them Americans
especially Christian Americans are kind
of entranced with the fact that we must
go to war we must go defend Israel and
listen I I want there to be peace more
than anyone but I don't think we should
get involved with a conflict at all
that's foreign I think we should be
focusing on our issues here like the guy
in the subway and um and I and I just
think that Americans are so funny as at
least Christian Americans and especially
those who call themselves conservatives
when they say let's not go to Ukraine
quit sending my lunch money to Ukraine